in this video I'm going to share with
you the four steps to getting your first
rent to rent deal if you don't know what
a rent to rent is I've done many videos
about this I'm going to leave in the
description explaining what a rent to
rent is but effectively it's when you
rent a property you take control of a
house you get the keys for the house
putting down very little is any money at
all and then you have permission to rent
the property out at a higher amount
meaning that you're getting a monthly
cash flow an income from the property
without owning it this is such a good
way to build your portfolio and start
getting a cash flow coming in to replace
your income without actually having the
deposit to go and start buying houses it
gives you experience it gives you good
cash flow it gets your foot in the door
and ultimately gives you an opportunity
to be able to leave your job with a
full-time income through property
without buying anything control is
sometimes better than ownership so if
you like my videos do me a favor hit the
like button share the video around and
drop a comment below and I'll try and
read every single one and respond to as
many as I can but in this video it's
about the four step perhaps to actually
getting your first deal so the first
thing you need is you need a game plan
when you're starting out you need to be
thinking okay hold on what am I actually
wanting to do here am I going to be
renting a property and then renting it
out on a room by room basis
and get pushing the rent up that way am
I going to be renting a property and
putting it on booking.com and Airbnb I'm
renting out on short stay let's am I
going to be utilizing housing
associations what's your actual plan
your strategy of pushing the rent up and
getting your first rent to rent so
there's different options but you need
to think what's the most congruent with
your skills maybe if you're really into
interiors and you love making things
look pretty service accommodation might
be a good method maybe if you are
currently living in a HMO and you're
thinking damn I'm paying 500 pounds a
month rent as is my housemate my house
make my housemate you've got a bit of
experience and understanding in HMO you
might be thinking well I could just rent
a house turn it into a HMO and profit
from all the extra extra rent so what's
your game plan what's your strategy also
what's your area I would suggest working
in an area where you know the area well
you know what the demand is like you
know what the supply is like and most
importantly is you need to actually set
up a company now this can be done for 12
pounds on company's house and it takes
actually about 20 minutes to go through
this process but you need a company
because this will give you protected
limited liability so get your
foundations set up your insurance is set
up also you might want to think about
your references have you got any
landlord references we can you afford
are you in a job can you afford to get
through that because normally you'll be
expected to earn
um considerably more than the rent that
you're paying so if you your salary is
really low and you're looking at
expensive properties are you going to
pass the references or do you need a
guarantor so the first thing is getting
your game plan because ultimately if you
fail to plan then you plan to fail step
two is about being sold on the service
of rent to rent before you sell it to
others what do I mean by that well
effectively when you're paying landlords
guaranteed monthly rent when you're
saying look I'll pay you a thousand
pounds a month for the next three years
rather than thinking and then I'll make
loads of money you need to be thinking
no this is not about you for a minute
why is this a good service for the
landlord one of the things that I do on
my rent to rent accelerator training is
I make my students right list all the
reasons for why a rent to rent would
actually benefit the landlord and
there's so many reasons I mean the
landlord hasn't got multiple tenants the
landlord hasn't is completely passive
the landlord doesn't necessarily need a
management company so they're saving on
costs the landlord isn't going to have
late payments they know what's coming in
maybe you could offer the landlord that
you'll pay any Light maintenance you
could do a small refurb of the property
if budget allows so what are all the
things
that you can offer to the landlord why
wouldn't the landlord just rent it out
themselves on a room by room basis or a
service accommodation well maybe they
haven't got the time they haven't got
the inclination so you're offering a
service to the landlord so that you're
you're giving them rent they know what's
coming in that of course they know that
you're going to make a profit but be the
second step is being really sold on the
service because you can't sell a
landlord unless you're sold yourself
first step three this is the hard bet
this is the bit that most people are
afraid to do is you need to actually go
and present the opportunity to as many
landlords and agents as you can now you
are going to get rejected there are
going to be some letting agencies that
say sorry we don't do that we don't do
company let's there's going to be some
landlords that are uncomfortable with
the idea of having people in and out
their house so once you once you've got
your company set up and you've got your
game plan and you've really sold
yourself on the service of what you're
doing you need to go don't start
pitching and presenting this to
landlords now a lot of people get really
bummed out because they say Samuel I've
been ringing landlords and no one's
interested and I'll say well hang on a
minute
how many landlords have you actually
spoken to and they'll say
maybe five or ten okay which one five or
ten five and I'll go let me see and I'll
go through their phone book and it's
four
so they've spoken to four landlords and
they've quit and how long does it take
to speak to a landlord and say hey I'm
looking to rent your property it's going
to be a company let this is working off
and before the landlord says no no I'm
not interested like a minute
so they've spent four minutes
trying to get a rent to rent and now
they want to quit you need to prepare
yourself mentally for this if you're
climbing a mountain it's going to be
very difficult climbing a mountain if
you prepare for a walk around a walking
around the garden because you're gonna
be like man I'm tired but if you're like
no this is going to take me 12 hours to
get to the top it's gonna be hard work
it's gonna be exhausting I'm gonna feel
like quitting but I'm gonna prepare
myself mentally it's the same when you
go to get a rent to rent you've got your
company set up you've got your game plan
you've got your you're sold on the
service but then you need to be like
right I need to speak to 50 people every
week which is only going to take me a
few hours a week and I'm gonna do that
like climbing a mountain and this is my
Mountain I'm getting to the top every
time I get a no I'm one step I'm one
step closer to my yes and I'm only going
to need a yes one yes to potentially
make me an extra thousand pounds a month
which brings me on to next step which is
step four the fourth step is when you do
get a landlord that says I'm open to it
yep I'm cool come and have a look around
the fourth step is putting forward your
offer doing your research and viewing
the property it's actually sealing the
deal and for this step you're going to
need to be very very simple which is on
formulas you need to work out
how much rent is the landlord asking for
let's say the landlord was asking for a
thousand pounds a month and it's a four
bed house and you you know that you
could rent the house out on a room by
room basis maybe it's already a hm it's
already set up as a HMO but you're
offering a thousand pounds well you need
to actually work backwards before you
put forward your offer you need to think
how much rent could I get for this
property in total if I could get 500
pounds of room that's 2 000 pounds next
who's gonna pay the bills who's gonna be
paying the council tax who you know
where where's my profit in all of this
because if you're paying a thousand
pounds and you're getting 2 000 pounds a
month rent but that doesn't include void
periods bills council tax management you
might only actually be left with two or
three hundred pounds a month so the
fourth step is make sure that every time
you get a deal your profit will be a
minimum of 500 pounds a month if you're
not making 500 pounds a month walk away
because quite frankly it's not worth the
hassle and also you need to have a
buffer in there so that if you've got
some empty rooms or some things happen
you've got your 500 pounds a month
buffer if it's more than that amazing
but you need to be making 500 pounds and
the second step to the formula is you
need to have made all your initial money
back within the first six months so if
you're doing a refurb for example or
you're getting Furniture don't spend ten
thousand pounds on furniture and carpets
when you're making 500 pounds a month
because that's five that's only going to
give you six thousand pounds in the
first year why would you spend ten
thousand pounds to then make six
thousand pounds after a whole year of a
property that you don't own you need to
make all of your money back within the
first six months those are the four
steps get a game plan next understand
what you're offering to the landlord and
what value it is next get out there and
start putting offers forward in a
professional way and then fourth make
sure that you do your due diligence your
market research your formulate your
offer properly and you'll make a minimum
of hundred percent of your money back
within six months plus 500 pounds a
month as a minimum monthly profit I hope
that helps smash the like button if you
did I'll see you next time